Alors, autre thématique, hein,
que vous portez cet après-midi à clairement féroce.
C'est tenu 1 rassemblement soutien à la Palestine.
Les
manifestants demandent 1 cessez-le-feu immédiat à Gaza.
Des membres de la lutte ouvrière était présent.
Quel rôle selon vous doit jouer l'Europe ?
Conflits ? Mais l'Europe
dans ce conflit ne pèse rien.
Celui qui a les clés de ce conflit,
de cette guerre que mène l'état d'Israël à Gaza,
c'est bien sur les États-Unis.
Ils ont la main sur le robinet de la finance,
ils ont la main sur les armes.
C'est les États-Unis qui financent, qui arment.
Euh, l'état
d'Israël. Et qui a dénoncé ici ce terrorisme d'État ?
Euh, c'est. C'est votre avis ? Et.